the fourth step
understanding the nature of reality
is so much more simple
than all of the complicated symbols
and concepts that have been
peddled
start with number one secretion
the fact that you exist
the fact that you are
i am that i am
are you aware
is there a being essence
do you find yourself in this dream
do you find yourself in this reality
do you find yourself having been born
from your mother
and her being born from her mother
and up the chain do you find yourself
having been secreted from this planet
sustained by this planet
do you find yourself bathing in the
ocean of oxygen
that you cannot find a clear edge
or boundary where you begin
and where the oxygen begins
so start with secretion
i exist i am i
am aware being essence
okay so all of us share that
all eight billion of us share the fact
that we exist
all eight billion of us share the fact
that we are aware
not male or female awareness
not black or white or asian or latino
being just being
just awareness without any
other identity
no identity of skin color of
religion of geography
of country of career a family
of friends of spouse of kids
of social media followers and accounts
just the fact that you are
just like everyone else has the fact
that
they are cool so we started with
secretion
once you've confirmed the fact that you
are okay i am
not these layers of onion identity
but just the pure aware beingness of
i am identified done
no clear boundary between me and this
oxygen
the same aware beingness is in all eight
billion of us
okay cool
so now what we do is we do step
two step
two is that you re-identify
as source as god
as the absolute there is
no difference between you and the
highest
there's no difference between you and
the supreme there's no difference
between you and the ultimate
it is literally a choice
to be a contracted energy of a
finite human trying to extract
peace and happiness from the creationary
dream
versus saying
i am the source of creation
i am god i am the absolute i am the
highest
i am the supreme i am the ultimate
my identity is literally the
endless big bangs that produce
all of this god at play with itself
in this universe with no separation at
all
i am what gives birth
to the oneness at play with itself
i am what gives birth
to the oneness at play with itself
i am what gives birth to endless oneness
at play with itself
i am what gives birth to endless leela
endless divine play you'll never come to
the end of all possibilities
ever that's what i am i am that
which can never come to the end of all
possibilities
i am god i am source i am the absolute i
am the supreme i am the highest
i am that which gave birth to this
entire
reality at play with itself
okay that's a choice
that's a shift that is the shift
and it is simply a choice
so step two is just re-identifying
yourself as the highest
and it's very intoxicative
maya the illusion
trying to extract peace and happiness
from the dreamed creation
substances experiences relationships
material possessions
it's very intoxicative it draws out your
identity like a big
pinocchio nose outward with all the
onion layers
and the very turn inward like in the
parable of the prodigal son catalyzed by
sledgehammers of suffering
creates this self-inquiry atma vichara
and as you do that process you dissolve
the pinocchio nose the ego the onion
layers and you become aware
of the very fact that you are
i am i exist i am aware
i have being essence which is shared
among
all eight billion of us that is the pure
god essence that we
share
and you identify yourself as the very
source of infinite creation i am that
which gives rise to
infinite leela infinite divine plays
that i'll never come to the end of
exploration
there is no separation between me and
all eight billion of us
there's no separation between me and the
oxygen that i inhale
there's no separation between me and the
trees and the birds and the bees
and the whales and the snails
no separation it's all one
beautiful big dreamed
reality
just like at night when i go to sleep
and i simulate out
a reality and the observation
of that reality there's no separation
between that observation
in the houses and the people and the
trees in the dreamed reality
there were many vivid lucid dreams
even for myself last night
just a couple of hours ago
i was simulating the people
that i was interacting with i was
simulating
the erotic experiences i was having i
was
simulating all of the profound
revelations and playfulness that was
occurring
there was no separation between myself
observing as awareness as being as i
am i exist in that dream and the dream
itself of all the people and
objects and places and experiences and
things
that is all oneness that is being
simulated by
the absolute by god by source i
am source simulating that entire dreamed
reality experience
just like i am source of this
dreamed reality creation experience
i am the source of this entire divine
play
just like i am the source of my dreams
divine play at night
so now that you've re-identified
yourself as source
you've re-identified yourself as god as
the absolute
you go to step three which is dissolving
the layers of egoic conditioning so what
happens is
that you first identify i am i exist
okay i'm the source of infinite creation
and this is all absolute oneness and
that
there is no separation and therefore i
am
serving the creation
with no attachment which we'll get to in
a bit but as you do that you recognize
that you have basically re-identified
yourself as the highest so if you go all
the way
all the way downstream is the person
all the way upstream is the source
so what you've done is you've shifted
your identity
from being this downstream person
separate finite entity
with a bunch of other separate finite
entities that you have no relationship
with
whatsoever the fish that does not know
what's in the ocean
and now you've become the very source so
you've went all the way
upstream okay so now that you've went
all the way upstream what's gonna happen
is
all of these downstream nonsensical
egoic conditioning is gonna bubble up
and arise so now you're going to become
source god the absolute
that is constantly dealing with all of
these egoic
conditioning inflammations these
onion layers of identity conditioning
that arise
and what you're gonna do as god source
the absolute
is you're gonna 100 percent accept
the fact that they are there
you are 100 going to accept
the fact that you are in the
exact essence that you are
as in i grew up without my father in my
life
so here's the difference i am the source
i am the one infinite creator that
created the scenario of this atlas mind
body spirit
complex having the experience of growing
up without a father
so now you see i am not the victim to
the scenario i am the creator of the
scenario and i have
radical love and acceptance for it
so do you see how as the source of
reality this egoic conditioning is going
to arise where it's like
hey are you sure you don't want to have
an inflammatory freak out about
some sort of lack belief or need to be
validated because you didn't grow up
without a father
and as the source what's going to happen
is i'm going to
accept the fact that that arose
and i'm going to patiently give it the
namaste
i bow to the divine in you thank you for
being
the egoic conditioning that was the tool
that i used for my awakening
and i give it the love and as i give it
the love what happens is that
it dissolves and integrates it's
transcended and included
the very inflammatory freak out of that
egoic conditioning
only has the power that you give it
so if you give it the power to create
fear and anxiety and depression and
control
and the inflammatory freakouts it will
do so
but once you become aware that i am god
i am the source i am the absolute that
created this scenario for myself to
awaken
i give it the love that it deserves the
acceptance that it deserves for
catalyzing this big sludgehammer of
suffering
that created my identity shift to being
the absolute
and upon doing that you will shine the
love light of the creator
on these layers of egoic conditioning
and radically love and accept them
and over time you will notice more and
more that it will dissolve
and be included it will be transcended
and included lovingly
and you will come less and less from
these most downstream
egoic layers of conditioning and you
will come perpetually
more and more from god's source the
absolute being
no separation all is my love light leela
and then you get to the point of
non-attachment
as you shepherd the awakening this has
been a very profound
revelation for me recently where
upon figuring out that even emptiness is
empty meaning even god source
the absolute has absolutely no
[ __ ] given whatsoever to its creations
yes they are all divine exploratory play
but there is no need or lack
whatsoever there is
no need for the creation to reach
a specific point in order for the
creator to be happy
emptiness does not need to be made happy
by the creation reaching a certain point
the emptiness is automatically always
already empty and free
and perfect period
and that's where the non-attachment
comes in so now
what happens is you realize i am the one
infinite creator
emptiness is empty so i have absolutely
no attachment
whatsoever to this creation awakening i
have no attachment to being a shepherd
whatsoever to this creation
that is so [ __ ] freeing and
liberating in itself
i am eternal i have no attachment
whatsoever to this creation that
is freedom that is liberation
and it actually makes you a better
shepherd because you stop
coming from the place of i am god i am
source i am the absolute and i have to
share
this information with everybody and
everybody has to awaken so that this
creation can reach all the sustainable
development goals
and that it can have its prosperity
maximized
coming from the place of lack or need
like that
is gonna turn everyone off
it's gonna turn everyone off everyone is
going to close themselves off
because you're coming from a place of
having a lack that needs to be filled by
somebody else awakening
i will know i will even as the creator i
will not be happy
until you awaken or i will not be
peaceful until the sustainable
development goals are met
that is ridiculously cancerous to the
actual creation
awakening the only way to be
the proper shepherd is to have
non-attachment
zero attachment none zilch
nada no attachment whatsoever
basically you are the creator you are
the source you are the very
emptiness that creates
the space for the creation to awaken
in its own divine unfolding
so you come from the mirror state
you are literally coming from the state
of being
a mirror i am serving the creation
awakening
i am shepherding the awakening of the
creation
by just holding the divine
empty space that is needed for the
creation to awaken
no attachment a mirror has no attachment
a mirror just sits
beautifully in silence in spaciousness
until another beautiful divine shard
of the one infinite creator
appears and
asks for purification
and this is where the effortless action
comes
where you can effortlessly steward
and shepherd the creation awakening
because you've had the appearance
in your mirror of a shard of the one
infinite creator
seeking to heal its confusion you've had
somebody appear
asking for your input
about meeting the sustainable
development goals
or about purifying one of their layers
of conditioning
zero attachment none
four steps it's so easy
you are the very infinite creation
i am that which gives rise to the
infinite creation
so upon that realization of i am the
very source of infinite creation
therefore i secreted
here in this beautiful dreamed reality
the first thing that i must do
is accept the fact that i secreted in
this beautiful dream to reality
i exist i am i am aware i
am being essence that is shared among us
all i
radically accept exactly where i'm at
in this dream creation design next i am
going to re-identify myself
as the very source of infinite creation
i am god i
am the absolute i am the highest
endlessly creating these creations for
myself to explore and play in
now i've re-identified myself away from
the downstream personhood
all the way to the most upstream
absolute supreme
ultimate source now
what happens is i'm going to fight off
all of these
layers of conditioning they're going to
dissolve
and integrate and then
i'm going to shepherd the awakening with
no attachment whatsoever because i know
that i'm
eternal i am the source i have no
attachment to this creation whatsoever
i'm gonna come from the place of pure
mirroring
that's the fourth step
infinite adoration with love light
unity thank you
you